[Music]
breath can't get high and people like
I'm gonna get high and do this interview
and I'm like I would get high instead of
doing the interview like that's how I
get down
there's no high end for me its high end
what that's that's the end man but I
know you when we in it when we talked
last time you're like you know more
these people that the weed doesn't keep
me from working you know you can just do
it okay would you would you smoke before
Last Comic Standing
do you do anything like that well you
know what like you really don't have
time okay
after that you know we don't start
probably till about 11:00 or so by that
time it's wore off and then you're not
taping to about cool the evening so four
or five so you know it's yeah it's just
like you want to fantasize I don't
Clayton one last comic standing and he
was high the whole time and
before after I go to work and I come on
be like rough day
yeah dude what a rough day for you
though you won I mean it was doing rough
but uh yeah you kind of Coast know you
killed every time really but how would I
know that see this is the thing people
don't know it's all nobody you didn't
see other people said yeah so you didn't
see anybody sick so just biased I guess
because it was you like a comedy but you
are - you were ripping Atlantic on me
the whole time you in the finals you had
the backdrop of the city man yeah what
does moves are lake in there's there
naked I don't know the skyline perfect
dude absolutely right but I like this
lake right here where is this you have
to put that in your rider next time I'm
pretty sure there is a lake I need to go
see what's so do about us sit down now
first off you're the first repeat on hot
breath come back I gotta say that you
come back boomerang back came right back
at you
yeah man because we had to sit down
again because you the first time we
talked this was a little over a year ago
and we're sit there was there was kids
running around in the background they
little I don't know what they were kids
but he's really makeup I cam in the baby
the kids briefed wrong she was like Lord
of the Flies out there so we when we're
when I'm interviewing you then this is
before you can even talk about Last
Comic Standing and all you say is like
it's gonna be a good year it's gonna be
a good year so there's all you could say
this is a pee
[Music]
and I was worried about like like I
don't want to say anything because I
don't want to miss right any funds of
court winnings yeah yeah prizes so when
we're talking in the interview you're
talking about like you know one month
it'll be great and I'm like old man I'm
doing comedy this is awesome and then
another month you're like I may die cuz
I don't have any money like that's where
you were in your career when we talked
last time yes and that was just so over
a year ago so how man how is it changed
on the brink of death and you do that
you love you should be no but just like
all I wanted was a chance at more work
like when I went in the land I
understand I just wanted to you know I
felt like okay if you're getting the top
ten you should be able to get a little
bit more so that was my goal just to try
to get in there to get a little more
work and winning the whole thing like my
agent he asked me like how many weeks
you want to work out of the year and I
was like how many weeks is 52 like I
need work at least and I think he gave
me like 48 I were probably working like
maybe 46 though and some stuff might get
dropped off and other stuff comes in
yeah do didn't like you The Last Comic
Standing tour alone you did like 70
shows in 90 days or 76 in 90 days we
cranked it I'm trying to shout out to
everybody I was on the tour with me too
man Dominique handbag Andy Erik's and
Michael Palin we did it that was like a
I mean because this you do a show then
you go home to the hotel for a little
bit load that bus up at 1:00 in the
morning you drive it to the next place
being like the place is closed and then
you can yeah you're on the tour bus
though you're although you still have
the boiler is still there
did you let us go cranks steel Craig I
don't drive it but okay you still
haven't for like sentimental values I
mean I still have it man like you know
like
ideally I put that [ __ ] in the movie
wouldn't it she's probably good song but
though I haven't got I haven't got a new
car and it's my mom's car that's what's
up man yeah it's 250 grand you know it's
the prize money I wrote and I you know
let me use her car to go all types of
show so I put quite a few miles on her
so it's only right I get her back you
know absolutely man yeah she's also your
like your manager now oh not my manager
he's my executive assistant I think
that's the title she gave her so okay
really she just booked my flights
brought around the team she needed to be
like oh yeah about two years and yeah
she just wasn't really doing what she
get laid off from she was working either
oh yeah she got laid off from there you
just kind of hit the house chilling and
not really just something you had like
told her one day like one day when I get
to a certain level I'm gonna kind of
bring you along with me was that some
goal you had well no but you know you
always tell your mom you want to take
care of yeah yeah like she always like
yeah but you know my mom would always be
like okay you got it
you know when you get older you gotta
buy your mommy a Jaguar but I get that
for my mom it's a Land Rover hey when
you get on don't [ __ ] on me son forget
about where you came from physically
came from I'll show you the scars if you
forget it
how did the money break down cuz it was
250 grand okay so it took a while to get
it to yeah like they break so little
check winnings is your prize
there's prize money right then there's
your development deal money okay and
then there's not like I forgot was prize
money and something else and then
development deal money so it was like
broke down three different ways prize
money that came first mm-hmm and that's
you know the taxes on that was no it's
another bracket but yeah so okay it was
good because when I wasn't making money
I was doing the last comic standing to
her right and that was just money coming
in and you never heard and they took
care of everything right yeah like I've
seen about the first hundred thousand
yeah okay and I'm not I'm not trying to
go you know I almost asked because I
want people to understand like they see
these TV shows and people winning this
quote money but they don't understand
like you don't win and then you go
backstage and they're like oh here's a
briefcase a process that you get it in
pieces
I felt partly like I was being like
punished for how I do my bill collectors
know I turned into the bill collector
hey can you pay anything what can you
put down load it right right right
just send me about what can I put you
down for $200 a week with interest you
get a charge out of interest oh you got
a break paranoid he let me go and give
you this water too in case you get
cottonmouth you got his own water people
yes I don't know where they said it
but he got it you got to be on the show
to get the water
oh yeah see this is why you need cameras
dude oh yeah you got a film and then you
show this right on the water I'm
struggling so on t-shirts right now
enough I could sell water that's a good
point
not everybody needs a t-shirt though
about going to the winner
t-shirts gonna be like that's a good
idea access your business
we're branding Oh No it's show business
what are you learn about it though um a
lot of stuff I learned is that it's just
it's relationships mmm what people had
like I'm in clubs I've never been to
before
I wasn't getting booked and that's
partly because the relationships at my
age enhance with these places his
reputation and of course the last kind
of a standing thing but when you have
somebody that put you in the is it's
hard to come from the ground like when
somebody vouchers for you is it's you
can move a little bit more lateral yeah
it's not necessarily this Hey um here's
my tape and you never because I got
tired of doing that with clubs I send
tapes and you send tapes and then you oh
yeah that was and you keep sending them
and you never you're nothing bad for
them you send them you email them you
said I just stopped doing it
mm I can't stop doing competitions I was
like I'm gonna work on getting do it
yeah and we're talking about this is
like an over ten year grind to get to
this point where you are now this is not
some like it's not some overnight like
cuz some people one last have one last
Comic Standing and they've been doing it
like two three years and they weren't
ready yeah so now you think that's why
it's there's a sustaining yeah and I got
a shout out one size of page or was just
the way they made you have any that
reality show stuff and I know some of
the people like you know I guess fans of
the show they they missed that but I'm
like that's what I'm glad we didn't have
like I was worried about that
probably I was like me in the audience
that's what I do yeah you hitting the
road this much there's got to be so many
crazy stories of experiences I mean I
just I saw one year somebody made you
chocolate with your face on it
the fans are crazy like you got to have
a crazy road story oh I mean we got hit
in the bus he was cool but he would also
you catch him doing shitty not supposed
to be doing driving the bus like texting
like eating a bowl of chili I swear like
just a movement it didn't feel I was
like we can't be on any major interstate
right now we got hit one night yeah and
he really did the right thing and
everything I mean it wasn't his fault
they you know yeah you also saw I was 32
buzz was and the bus driver got his got
pickpocketed by some loose women of the
evening oh oh when he bring one back to
the bus no buzz we load up the bus they
come up targets whoop she started by
grinding her ass you know like even the
bus charmer has groupies so like what
about they were trying to get to you I
guess after a baseball game too so I
just seen him talking to some other dude
[Music]
you had any fun run Ensor you see that
you see the business picking up what
about you know the play no they say
business and pleasure or whatever so I
was just that was really a segue and
asking oh no I mean this really like I
really don't do a lot of [ __ ] just work
just work like but I can do the stuff I
want to do that's what I do some tests
like if I go to plays like I'm gonna
check out whatever yeah sorry I feel it
my brain a little bit it's like yeah so
like I'm trying to focus now but like so
like you said I went to women's rugby
I'm like oh that's cool
we'll just play it yeah we'll just play
it because I used to I used to have to
add a lot why because my interviews were
horrendous and I would just be like um
so here's another question here's a
different question a lot of did a lot of
oming no questions yeah this is episode
I mean you know I've done over 50 now so
it's just it's a lot like span uh penis
the more you do it the better you get at
oh you've been trying to get me to do it
for a minute - you've been working man
but this is perfect timing because you
just headline to show it red-clay we're
here in Atlanta for the red clay
festival so yeah Atlanta comedy that's
what this whole games about what's the
moment you had with all your travels and
everything like what's a moment
where you're like oh I made it like and
I know you're still working I know
you're still learning and developing but
what's the moment you're like wow I've
hit another level here why okay this is
the end of the left Comic Standing so
our last show Hawaii the next day I
spent the whole day in Hawaii didn't
have nothing to do my flight left for
like eight or something that night I'm
out there I'm sitting on these rocks
like these volcanic rocks on the ocean
looking at like okay but then after that
is like back to work right so you could
physically hear her talking to you like
you heard audibly everything was just so
perfect - so this is like the island
where they shot Jurassic Park so like
you know you being like just a tropical
or cheap you know I'm saying like it's
like a flower garden but it's all these
plants you're never gonna see anywhere
else
mm-hmm just being out there
congratulations oh yeah but now it's
back to work so like what it what does
that entail now for you it's just just I
got approached to TV like I did comedy
mmm next up I'm kind of fuel each other
I want to maximize my economy so I feel
like that TV to TV movies that's the
other side of it I'm treated comedy like
a grind like a craft I've worked on it
you know practice this repetition that's
all that way if you want that same
success in other areas you got to apply
that same discipline you know even if
it's foreign this year
was for the media one point but how
about people like with TV projects like
have you been in meetings we're like
okay Clayton you're the man you're the
lead this is what we got for you you got
a family and you're gonna be a
schoolteacher okay
got this they're gonna be this guy right
there you get him intrigued then you
start trying to put the pieces in you
need to start right so you get them you
know okay now I got this room okay
well sure okay we'll do that okay let me
show you this person now you got a
person that likes it and they got kind
of the same mindset and they were a
writer
so they know how to write it for TV so
you get that first and then you figure
out okay well what kind of show do I
wanted to be so you know I gotta get a
showrunner you know I'm saying it's when
you started looking at like okay this
person worked on this show and this is I
think my show should be kind of like
this so I think they got the same you
know feel the vibe I do so let me put
them and you you you really want to like
bring it to them all together mm-hmm
you got to have everything that's that's
comforting to know though that you you
have the power though I mean you do but
I mean you go take it tell you what you
can't do take another direction you know
the whole goal is to you know give them
something that they that's uniqueness
gonna hook them in yeah pull them in
just keep pulling what have you been
working on that direction another
another guest I've had on here of course
is somebody you started with Carlos
Miller yeah who have interviewed on here
who he had two strippers with him yeah
he called it his Rick James moment
another reason I should be filming this
not for the water but it was a precedent
oh I would have had some I did I just
walk into his place there's two girls
there okay his fight and then she he's
just like ah man should we pay these
women to get naked and I was like should
you pay these women to get naked and
then they did and they sat there naked
and I'm trying to interview him he's
doing the same thing you're doing right
now there's smoke in the air and I'm
trying to there's smoke in there and
naked women I'm trying to like focus and
be like well tell me why you're the next
Martin Lawrence while like all this is
happening to my face it isn't talk yeah
he was on Doug Benson's getting Doug
with high you got to get on there man
yeah oh really
we're at the same College like we had
before I knew he was ready to profile
because they had the bright light
shining like across the highway there on
the side Wow the whole lights was like
you go do the lightning like what color
are you okay good he got behind this and
then he was like well you know there's a
lot of human trafficking going on I was
like stealing people in the end they all
of Babel he's like yeah you'd be
surprised
wow man you got off though I guess you'd
be surviving we didn't have nothing in
the car we had a smoke earlier but like
he taught a car up looking for
everything and he didn't find another I
had was sick so I kept spitting up like
mucus mmm but I was spitting it in like
this like McDonald's bag like you know
saying that we had from the trip so like
I saw him like digging the bag
[Music]
and I used all the sanitizer we had in
the car and he came back and he was
pissed
Wow
what I love about your comedy and
watching you headline the first show at
relapse last night for red clay and see
I hadn't seen you do like a headliner
set in a while and when I interviewed
you the first time I was like you know
you do a lot of weed material like do
you feel like you want to start straying
away from that and you were totally
you're like no I mean I talk about what
I know but seeing you last night
you're you talk about weed a little bit
and like maybe sex some like the
majority of it was like politics and
like social commentary and like race and
everything you had an amazing joke about
getting pulled over by the police and
you're like we're scared of each other
now like looking in the rearview mirror
at each other
kids on the intercom I'll let you go if
you let me go or whatever I don't want
to butcher the joke I mean that's just
something but yeah I can't not talk
about this right and I've had you know
probably people like that that have told
me you know you came well you know
really well I probably need to say it
the most mainly white people is that
yeah so are you trying to steer your
material more into like maybe sending a
message and really start to try to
mainly you know I mean I feel if I
thought if I said on stage one is it's
because I think it's funny too
I think it's a point that other people
are making like if this is how we're
gonna this is the society we're gonna be
in there where everything is just little
all you got to do is say something smart
and say something slick and it's taking
a sec okay let's [ __ ] do that like
I'm a [ __ ] comedian that's what we do
like right you want to spin some [ __ ]
like you they try to spin [ __ ]
and I'm like come on man like you can't
keep hitting us with the same lines zero
and at some point if somebody doesn't
start to deconstruct it in and like stop
taking it at face value and being like
know what you're saying is this book
which you really mean is this you're
trying to cover for this mm-hmm
you know some people out there that's
so-called whoa where there's a lot of
people is this that they think they
won't put is away you've got to go about
doing it you know you have to if you
want people to listen to you do you see
yourself maybe thinking outside of
comedy as well and maybe anymore like
social activism so you know you want to
take what some of I'm saying in comedy
and just look into if it makes you look
into stuff further it makes you and I
see what stuff is but we also know when
people [ __ ] like I know [ __ ] in
any language [ __ ] is that [ __ ] is
universal I don't have to understand
language I can look at your body is that
a big resource for your material you're
always scanning because we talked about
I keep forever saying the first
interview I don't know why but if people
haven't heard it they should listen to
it as a point of reference for Judy you
said
good yeah I mean we're all getting
better here boy you said we said in that
interview was that um there's the UM I
gotta be real I totally forgot where I
was going yeah you killed me man oh you
you looked for you said you look for a
lot of material in conversation and like
when you get a laughing conversation
you'll take it to this stage are you
looking for like you said like [ __ ]
if something comes off as [ __ ] is
that like kind of where your materials
coming from now okay who said this how
can I like I'm looking at everything
never mind everything from material
brain yeah when I guess also like I'm
I'm not even much right right yeah it
must be crazy though in just a year's
time to go from like just trying to
scrape by
- now booked week after week in front of
in front of audiences not night clubs
with people smoking hookah and texting
like these are comedy shows yeah I are
you overwhelmed look what is this is
what you prepare for yeah show has to be
different and then when you come back
and you do a smaller so you might have
to make an adjustment that comedy clubs
show and you come and you do like a bar
show or a lounge show there is a
different feel in a certain level of
different stuff you up there for our
that stage is big you've got to use that
whole stage you know you come to so a
smaller venue and you know you might
have to shrink it down perform for the
room like accordingly you adjust yeah
yeah
his animation and all that you know like
some places super tight Shido to me
think of you act out person that you do
these strong egg - you go kick somebody
in the face yeah but your act out dude
likes watching last night your act out
I've hit a new level I mean is that
something you're aware of and that you
were trying to work on yeah just trying
to make it so mm-hmm it comes with a
we'll see you guys on the show it has to
be they have to be taking it
you got to paint that picture they'll
write which they'll go where ever the
[ __ ] you take them but it's up to you
how much how do you take them they're
like is it just confidence the stage
time you have any pointers on how to
take them to that point talking about
I've got a shown how you see it in your
mind hmm
so funny to you it's funny enough for
you to go up there take it to the stage
then you have to present it to the way
to do so it little mean so that they'll
go with you and then it's up to you how
much you show know how descriptive are
you mm-hmm or you to does good how fast
did you get to the point can you show
them how you you know you show them how
you felt in this moment is there's a lot
of factors to it but everybody has a
different recipe for they so right you
just have to figure it out I mean yeah
that's what I was trying to get into the
recipe you know but certain ingredients
that certain recipes need like a
detailed point of view and act out like
yes it could be you know I don't know
you suppose we're making whatever this
casserole is it's some casserole and
this is you know you need to put you
need flour you need cheese you need egg
you need 2 cups of salt and you don't
put the salt in there mmm will be [ __ ]
up mmm but it's not what it was supposed
to be because you didn't put the rice so
it might just be once you know I'm
saying you might need to take a word out
I need to add another might need to you
know put the punch line further away you
might need to put it close you might
need to make the pearls clear it can
always be something yeah yeah you have
that joke about getting pulled over by
the police and him finding like a roach
and then he pulls you out of the car and
it's sitting on the police car and it
ends up you like eat the roach and like
then you go I'm not gonna butcher
another one of your jokes but like soap
for that joke old studio I remember one
time you told a joke about a pair of
slacks joke was amusing to me because I
had on slasher not out Metsu I was use
that joke as a point of reference for
maybe like the recipe oh yeah we're
gonna choose for ya
because a lot of people listen no
because I like the I like talking shop
and I find that my listeners like to
hear shop especially from somebody you
know no joke
because you can you can see when you
were talking about that joke I could see
you standing by the car they can see sit
in the car in the cop showing up so like
what are what are parts of the recipe
that bring that visualization you just
you just you everybody seeing from some
point
either you saw because you drove past
are you sorry because it was you you
know I mean are you saw because you was
in the passenger seat while on the press
are everywhere so is a quick point and
then you set way you will you got it you
know you just set the tone for joke
sometimes you've got a you got a and
don't have to be one way to Hubble time
loop this beat up through the slow Diana
is really up to you I call shows like
that you might just want to slow down so
you paint a picture better describe
everything so you know the situation I
mean now now it's oh [ __ ] I'm probably
going to jail for sure so you know to
move mmm okay that's the shot so yeah
yeah yeah all right cool I won't hold
you hostage much longer than I know
you're good so we we talked about you
know where you've come from where you
are maybe as a point of reference maybe
where you're going because I referenced
Carlos Miller earlier who you started
out comedy with now you guys are doing
this awesome podcast 85 South yeah well
it's Atlanta podcast it is stupid but
it's entertaining
yeah Roger
we chase jokes down we've had to let our
female hey don't feel upset if you get
cut off or you don't finish your thought
it's not that nobody didn't want to hear
it you said something funny or stupid
and we chased that [ __ ] yeah yeah in the
name of comedy you know yeah you know
once they realize that yeah yeah I
highly recommend it there's a lot of
good podcast here in Atlantis 85 South
was definitely one of those like it's
like a Fight Club for comedy yeah
correction is talented comics just let's
see if we find it sometimes we don't but
we have fun either way sometimes you're
like what are they doing right now
what's why am i listening to this but
you're right because that's the hottest
talent yeah I need to get both of them
on here now that you say that make that
happen for Atlanta podcast but yeah and
you and Carlos you know you've been
working together for over the years you
guys working on like a TV show or some
you guys trying to join forces I'll take
you to that so what it what is what's
what's the what's the the goal now man
you're starting to actually get that
power and that like influence behind you
where do you want to steer this energy
man what's what do you envision anybody
know you know but if it comes to making
money you know it's not some bad
examples out there Seinfeld comes to
mind
mm-hmm you know when it comes to the
bread that is that you're able to get
out there so you know Amy Schumer he's
still a brand now that you got to think
in that direction Clayton English is no
longer just a comedian he's a brand so
like are you thinking like Kevin Hart I
want to have my own shoes I wanna have
my own clothing line I want to have my
own TV show likes what I feel you're not
like an undistorted zora [ __ ] there's
not so straight
the custom [ __ ] like I don't know where
the NBA players give a [ __ ] for my
ankles ain't right to be I know Cam
Newton yeah you made it you know where
genes that are pre torn so like you've
made it dude yes you've earned it though
man and it's well deserved and your hard
work has paid off and now you can
actually start to just create your own
Empire dude yeah so just don't forget
about me TV shows movies let's do it man
well thank Clayton English man before we
get out of here is there anything else
you want the world to know yeah I'm out
here Clayton English on everything all
your social media 85 South shall we
drive when all Fridays and Clayton enjoy
everything cleanings calm and also let
you know where I'm gonna be all my shows
coming soon of coming to a area near you
so be on the lookout you have a website
now yeah good cuz when we talked last
time you're like I don't know anything
social media will follow him he's taking
a call thank you so much Clayton English
before I called yourself
[Music]
my breath